hello and welcome to this video playing
FIBA with black I'm going to do
something that I normally not do
it's risky to but with the Gruner a yeah
it's not part of my opening repertoire
but let's see how we how we fare with
the goon felled yeah this is this is
actually kind of dangerous as far as I
know there are some who does that work
here I know that this is the line of
this is a theoretical line do you
actually play Bishop f6 or is there some
technical trick there I kind of I have
this odd feeling that there is some
trickery here
[Music]
I know some 95 or whatever this is that
this is sometimes there's a problem with
the Grunfeld it's an excellent opening
but there are many lines that white can
play where you need to be very precise
and well I don't know why it would know
the noise can see I kind of fear this is
what I what I what I said what I
suspected to happen
okay so age six kicking this back on
[Music]
[Music]
hmm I didn't expect that Bishop takes
pawn takes why is that good I mean at
the end he identified false is that the
problem
Bishop takes pawn takes pawn takes Queen
f6 check text text in genetics at the
anti 5/4 that's a problem okay if I take
g5 pawn takes Queen takes Queen checks
that's worse okay so if I take with the
Queen taketake and I takes d5 yeah it's
the problem some player with the which
is 7 hanging mmm yeah but I don't really
see much else down each 5 just looks
terrible if I take what the pawn that is
Queen to f6 and don't like that so okay
c7 is not possible really to keep 96
looks bad so I have to play actively
white is better you no doubt but it's I
couldn't really find couldn't find a
better solution so he's a pawn up
I'm currently threatening rook c8 though
it's a little bit uncomfortable on the
sea farm not sure that long castles was
best maybe but it's done a bit of a
problem
rook define sorry 95 I can go work the
aid that should win the pawn bag
[Music]
probably this one threatening a six okay
I totally missed that idea that's bad
missing this is bad very stupid
now that I absolutely cannot miss 96 I
mean if you miss that you lose you lose
the game
Roxy one is probably strong now maybe I
can take the form not really yeah yeah
let's see what he does this one can't
and they cannot take haha what a game
and I played really badly I did sit sir
it's just this is opening the this
opening is tricky I know why I never
played the Grune felt in the tournament
game always [ __ ] sorry
even this is this this stupid move as
possible never played the green fur
because I always felt you you need to
know that many specific lines and then
you you forget something and somebody
beats you just out of out of out of
their opening book basically and that's
something that I never want to have was
probably good
mmm-hmm that is an awful pin
I can never unpinned us a problem I mean
only with the rook trade and it's
obviously not going to go into do it
and basically anymore foods for white
almost maybe not king c3 or something
like that but nobody is going to play
that I came 94 probably it's just too
simple technique
not quite sure what he's doing there but
you you win here with white pretty much
regardless
[Music]
now it's still completely lost
I'm just taking be sixes enough not the
only one of course
across the lawyer employee cannot give a
check there against the q6
and King King yet it doesn't work yeah
then it was the position was too bad I
mean it was just too bad out of the
opening
I shouldn't shouldn't do it but I'm kind
of tempted sometimes to try different
things so what we should have 6h for
maybe King g7 is already bad then should
go
h6 first maybe it seems yeah this is
this is really a bit of a problem there
I mean he basically got the point from
the opening here you you just have a
position anymore
so King g7 was bad then I have to start
with this move after this then whatever
King g7 also at least that avoids
immediate problems and this is really a
brilliant already a c5 is a big threat
95 don't know D take seems to be best
switch ok I didn't quite see how bad
this is
h/h takes yeah then then do then you got
this yeah that's also problem ok I hit
King a raid yeah this may be a little
bit more interesting I mean even always
get the 5 & 6 7 I only calculated this
and okay this is actually even even
worse it's just a bad position
yeah Jim and long castles
this is bad but the position is probably
it's beyond repair I guess what I have
here of course I should see 96 that was
silly that I didn't didn't see that one
which is kind of easy I had a position
issues too bad yeah the engine gives me
a couple of more question mark moves but
you you just the position is completely
rotten and I don't think I had some
opportunity anyway i I I'm just just too
bad shape
so you have to be alert here King g7 was
bad young played this reasonably quickly
yeah just age six and young your okay
and this is again this is a bit of an
issue with the groom for elders
especially when you played in in blitz
and you don't don't know where they'd
have to find stuff that can be a problem
it's not it's not my opening ok guys
thanks for watching